[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the cat fancy
podcast we are ready to answer your
questions about
uh cats and uh i don't know whatever
else
i see no questions about cats and
frankly i'm disappointed in all of you
no questions about cats at all we are in
a goofy mood it must be hanukkah that's
what it's doing
it's hanukkah yep it is the festival of
lights yep it's a giddy holiday
it's one way of looking at it all right
um we're going to start with a few
questions from last time
move on to a question from the discord
we take one question from the discord
every week
and then start answering your questions
from last hour
all right what is your take on this
great reset idea that is being pushed
forward by the wef that's the world
economic
forum right not fund uh and the davos
group
it seems like a utopian dream at best
and a totalitarian nightmare at worst
either way it gives me the creeps yeah i
would say it's it's like
there are many such things where
a great reset might be a wonderful thing
and actually you would imagine that at
this moment where we are suddenly
discovering that all sorts of things
that we thought were bedrock and
unchangeable are changeable because
we're forced to it by covid that um
you know this might be the moment for
such a thing but do i trust the wef
and davos folks to reimagine the world
in some way that will be
better for us or do i expect the
totalitarian nightmare is uh the more
likely scenario i would have to say i
fear the
the latter yeah me too and i don't i
have not really spent any time with it
so i just don't know the specifics
um seems like a utopian dream at best i
would say that doesn't sound like an at
best because utopia is an impossibility
is there are there considerably
major reconstructions that could be done
that could make for a better future yes
i absolutely believe so do they involve
static rules
no no they don't so um
utopia fails in part because it imagines
a static
a static future or static state of being
in which everyone is somehow blissfully
well in which tradeoffs have been
obliterated
and so has reality frankly yeah i agree
the utopianism is a problem but also the
uh
the inability to resist the opportunity
to um
as long as we're making utopia it might
as well rig it a little bit in our
direction that thing will result in a
disaster
almost no matter what let's see can we
can we borrow the line from animal farm
uh everyone deserves utopia but we
deserve utopia even more than the rest
of them
yes we deserve a higher grade of utopia
based on our equality as people
yeah yeah okay uh next question from
episode 57
what can you advise on navigating all
the equity related requirements seem to
be a part of every advertised faculty
position
in north america um
i do not know what to answer to this i
am certain that were i
faced with this it'd be
impossible to go through these trainings
quietly
well no this is not trainings this is
equity-related requirements
that are part of every advertised
faculty position and i would say
actually
um so this is then about the
requirements that your
position that your qualifications be
equity-based
uh i don't think so that's not how i
read it um that you know that
that would presumably either include or
exclude you so there's no there's
nothing you can do to change it those
characteristics are immutable except for
trans
as i've said before um
[Music]
but with regard to you know okay well
you have a research statement and a
teaching statement now maybe you have an
equity and diversity statement that you
have to write this is what i suspect is
going on
and i think in this regard the reason i
included this question we always get
questions about like what
what would you do if you were stuck in
this hell right now
and uh weirdly and this will maybe not
be surprising to those who
uh view evergreen as a caricature of
itself always
um as opposed to we who who very much
loved the institution
um but um found it gameable and gamed
um we loved
aspects of the institution it's founding
but it sounded like what you were saying
was that we found it gameable and gamed
it but obviously that's the inverse of
what you mean
which i know you know but it sounded
sounded that way it was it was gameable
uh it was gamed that was true all along
even so we we loved it and found much to
be done there that you couldn't do
anywhere else
um but actually from a long time back
and i don't know
how long in advance of when i applied
and would have been 2000
i guess i started in 2002 so when i
applied in 2001
um there was effectively an equity and
diversity statement already they didn't
call it that yeah um but
we and i didn't know of any other and
certainly none of the other faculty
applications that i made had it um and i
don't remember exactly what the framing
was but it basically asked you to write
uh about some aspect of your life that
you thought
made you uh able to see
into uh other people's lived experiences
and that wouldn't have been the language
that they used
um and you know it may have you know it
may have given examples that included
things like
race sex um et cetera um
and you know the fact is i don't
actually remember no i do think i know
i think i know kind of what i wrote and
i think i do know what you wrote
and in both of our cases because we'd
spent a lot of time living and doing
research
in a lot of other parts of the world and
we just had experience
actually engaging with people who really
didn't share
any almost any demographic features with
us
and we engage with them as human beings
not as
you know not as exhibits to to marvel at
um it was it felt relatively easy and
almost
um almost like an interesting
opportunity actually to say
hey actually this is something that most
people should should
should seek to do which is engage with
people who really are different from
themselves
i agree although i remember i remember
writing it i know exactly what i wrote i
wrote about
my first research gig in jamaica and i
wrote about the fact
that being the only white guy for
10 15 miles in any direction which i was
for
much the time i was there revealed
certain things about being a minority
and it did not change other
things because white was still white yep
and i remember and you didn't live there
permanently you can always go home
right but i remember a member of the
committee
alerting me i think after i had been
hired to the fact that the committee had
not
liked my statement really which shocked
me
because my sense was i mean frankly if i
had to write the statement today
i'd write the same statement and focus
on the same things because i think it
was the right answer to the question
but the i think frankly there was a
desire to see
yes exactly and because this didn't have
that nature to it
i think the thing is i got hired because
i was well understood
to be a very effective evergreen
professor even if some people didn't
like
the way i taught everybody knew that i
was
very popular with students and that many
felt that they were getting
you know a kind of educational
experience they they wouldn't get
elsewhere
um and so anyway i got hired in spite of
my statement
and i still think the statement was high
quality and the right answer so i think
that was an ominous sign of what was to
come
which means an answer in the answer to
this question boy do we not know
yeah um i just i don't know i never got
feedback on
the statement part of my application um
but that was also a lot earlier yes it
was
mine um and and the people on my
committee
um were with one possible exception if
anything anti-woke
before woke was a thing but like really
highly resistant to any of this kind of
thinking
right got it i mean you can you can
imagine who these you know who these
people were
yeah yeah they were they just they held
no truck with
the kind of intersectionality and such
whereas on your committee there was a
certain amount of that
not only did they hold no truck but not
even a small car
they held no car yeah what is that
expression from i'm not sure exactly
probably it has nothing to do with
trucks no i expect not yeah yeah
okay third of four questions from
episode 57
brett mentioned earlier in the podcast
that the renegotiation of gender roles
are long overdue
i'm curious to know what concessions he
would like males and females to make
respectively
well i mean i definitely feel it's a
privilege and an honor to be able to
negotiate on behalf of both sides
here that strikes me as very right um
no i look i think um
i don't think it's that kind of a
renegotiation and i think you know this
is one of the things
i think you and i have slam-dunked this
right because our our relationship is
entirely um non-traditional
with traditional elements where they
make sense right it is
a very symmetrical relationship almost
to an absurd degree in the sense that
you know we had the same job at
evergreen we continue to have the same
job
right you can't seem to avoid having the
same
role in the universe the same access to
healthcare all of these we have the same
children
thank god you know i was i was just
waiting to see
one of the children has killed the power
into the computer
i think they're a little surprised and
may be disappointed to discover that
that is in fact the case
um but no the the answer to the question
is look lots of things have been altered
by this landscape
that provides us with certain freedoms
that our ancestors wouldn't have had and
it exposes us to some hazards that they
wouldn't have faced
right to the extent that you're just
applying a traditional
uh set of norms it's relatively
straightforward and you just sort of
accept the costs and benefits that come
with them
in our case basically i'm up to see
um anybody
establish what role they want so long
you know it's kind of frankly a little
bit of
um a libertarian approach with respect
to gender roles i'm up but it's
libertarian in the sense that i would
uh and i have argued on this podcast
that libertarians are under imaginative
typically about
harm and so the point is you should
essentially be free
to do anything that doesn't have harmful
consequences
to others but harmful consequences
flowing to others are much easier to
produce than you think
and so you really often invisible
sometimes long term just like what we
were talking about in the first hour
today
yeah you know what
what might be the long-term consequences
of introducing women into
military outfits right right um
even you know if it's not hand-to-hand
combat there's nothing about the
physical nature of the work
that is going to be compromised by the
fact that on average women are not as
strong upper body strength
might there be long-term effects that
would render such a force
less coherent in an emergency situation
i don't know
i hope not but i don't know well and it
might be different
for infantry versus you know pilots
yes right yes um very much so
so anyway there's something to be
navigated there and it is also
highly likely in fact i would argue it
is uh
very close to certain that even in
places
where it can be done in such a way that
it doesn't harm our
military effectiveness that there are
much better and worse ways to do it and
so anyway
a sort of sensitivity to you know in the
case of the military i think we have a
particularly
clear case which is um this is the place
where our aspirations for
equality and other such values
have to be secondary to our ability to
protect
the nation from harm which doesn't mean
they're unimportant but it means
you know it's just as you don't want
somebody bursting into
you know an operating theater and
interrupting your heart surgery to you
know
count how many people of different races
are in the room and
try to establish equity right right the
point is there's a
there's a hierarchy of significance
and in the case of the military
individual aspirations
uh are not the highest priority right
i keep trying to figure out how to
phrase this right the military
has in fact a been very well integrated
for much longer than many structures
freshly integrated right now it's not
just that's not its history originally
right but the point is it has
and it was sort of like at a gross level
integrated before it was actually like
interspersed integrated right i mean
they were separate they were different
units right and then
there weren't and so there are ways in
which uh people
who weren't traditionally working next
to each other have been put in that
position and the military's figured out
how to do it and do it well
it also is weirdly like the most
socialist um entity around it
neutralizes differences between people
at many scales but then it also creates
this hierarchy so it's like
you know socialism stacked on top of
each other or something
but anyway the point is it doesn't it
you know to the extent
that the us military is fighting for
liberty
it's like an it's not and
uh it is the opposite of liberty on the
inside right it is constraining
by necessity in order to make it
effective on the battlefield you don't
want a bunch of people
you know doing their individual
calculations on the battlefield you want
people to function as a
coordinated entity and so anyway
my only point would be uh there are
places for
these discussions and there are the
places where these discussions have to
be secondary to
a mission that is so critical that you
don't dare upend it before you know
exactly how it works
yeah so anyway with respect to men and
women there's lots of room for
renegotiation
we need to be cautious about what we
don't know about what happens with all
sorts of things
you know obviously women being in the
workforce has been
fantastic the number of things women
have accomplished
you know in for example the scientific
milieu
is huge right so this is obviously a
good thing did it come without
complexity
no and in fact we still haven't figured
out all of the complexities of how it's
supposed to work
so anyway it's a work in progress and to
some degree we yell at people who try to
talk about the complexity yes
yeah absolutely
final question from a week ago are you
familiar with winhoff's cold exposure
and breathing techniques
what are the evolutionary benefits of
regular cold exposure and conscious
breath work
also brett you need to learn drums let
eric play guitar heather on keys
i think unfortunately we'll be best off
if eric is
uh on guitar and keys and maybe drums as
well
yeah um right um
there was a moment when me on keys would
have been um plausible but
not at this point yeah at this point
okay well i just i never i never had
your brothers
i had years and years and years of
classical training but i never had your
brother's ability to
sit down and improvise he's
he and i have tried to to get there get
me there together and it just hasn't
worked
yes and he the most amazing story here
which eric has talked about i think on
the portal
at some length uh is his son
zev who has picked up this ability
and it arrived out of almost nowhere yes
um i said if you're listening i i say
this with love but
yeah he was absolutely inept until one
day he wasn't and it was like over the
course of
weeks he we saw so it was fantastic
right around
i can pinpoint it because we were there
with with um
for zeb's bar mitzvah so this is going
to be like a year and a half ago
ish i think no i guess two and a half
years ago yeah
um two and a half years ago and uh he
was just it had been weeks at that point
and he was already
just doing extraordinary extraordinary
things yeah
well in fact when i heard it i it
sounded a lot like eric
and i assumed it was eric and then it
couldn't be here because eric was over
there
and it was like instead of recording um
and so it really
it really did come out of nowhere and it
wasn't you know
it's clear that at least one component
of the story
is that zev had the music on board
having heard it so many times you know
heard the
the various riffs and things and so then
when his fingers
all the time yeah when he his fingers
figured out how to make the sounds come
out of the keyboard
suddenly it was like well there was a
lot to say right right
um so anyways it's an amazing uh
amazing fact yeah do you know anything
we've been asked before about wim hof
and i like i i know the name but i don't
know much about the
particulars so i i don't know whether
there's more to it i i um
i was on a podcast it's not out yet but
a psychologist was talking to me about
all sorts of things quite a good uh um
quite a good discussion um
jeremy lee quinn anyway that'll be out
and i will announce it but we were
talking about
um how one prepares
for extreme circumstances he was in fact
asking me about how
why i did relatively well
at evergreen when things came apart and
you know i talked about developmental
uh preparation you know just stuff that
happens to you that causes you
to have those those skills and
immunities and whatever else it might be
right but i also talked about the
process of toughening
yourself up right and there's something
about confronting
uh confronting things that
force you to go through
something unpleasant or difficult in
order to just generate those
skills whether it's fasting or breath
control or
whatever or i mean and i i raised this
in the last hour you know literally at
11 30 last night
you geared up and took your bike out yes
and it was in
freaking cold um but it was neither
raining nor icy it wasn't that cold it
was in the mid 30s yeah
um would have been a mess if it was icy
yeah but i would have i would have
asked you not to go yeah um but
you know it didn't look appealing to me
yeah and i don't think it looked
appealing to you either but you knew the
value in it yeah
and um and it you know it has
you can in this case like you have
something that you're counting
which helps you make sure that you meet
that you get a certain number of these
rides in just so that you meet some
rubric right but you know that that
thing that you're counting isn't
everything that there's every reason
that there's value in it no no no i'm
just gonna bike to the peak this many
times in a month and i'm gonna bite the
river in the peak
that's that's fine and good but there's
also value and i'm gonna do that
in july when it's easy and i'm also
gonna do it in december when
oh my god i gotta also be paying
attention to is this the moment okay i
better go
ready so actually it reminds me um there
was one
year i can't remember what year
was must have been 2012 2013 something
like that
when i was really trying to push the
number of miles
per year that i was riding and so i was
really just
i was being brutal on myself during the
winter and forcing myself to ride long
distances
and it was you know it was cold this
pacific northwest it's not that cold but
it's cold enough to be grueling
and um i think i got six thousand miles
that year which is
probably my record this would have been
also the year that in the spring you
were training for the ramrod
right to ride around mount rainier one
day which i didn't end up doing because
uh
my grandfather harry died and i got sick
but anyway i trained for it which
involved some centuries
and things like that but anyway those
who don't bike
century is riding a hundred miles a day
which is um
very doable it's not something you can
set out and do without
working up to it's very doable number um
you know
five or six hours of dedication and then
you know it's like sore and hard to walk
for the rest of the day
um anyway uh
oh yes so i was doing this i was going
all winter and i really forced myself
not to get knocked off the horse at any
point
and then at the end of the winter as
spring dawned
and biking started getting easier
and the weather started getting nice i
swear
it was like wonderful drugs
flooded my system you know there was
something about the
process of having gone through all of
that unpleasantness that then as it
began to ease it was just like
oh my god this is delightful you know
yeah so anyway um so you're taking your
medicine now as it were
i think that's a bad analogy given what
the kinds of things we talk about but
you're
you're accepting the down part of the
trade-off now knowing
that the upswing will come yes and also
as you point out there's lots of
stuff that you know there's lots of
goodness that flows to you even as
you're just
forcing yourself to do something that
doesn't really feel like it's that much
fun you get out there and actually
it feels really good to be out yeah and
it feels really good to get back
and uh no i mean this this fall in the
pacific northwest has been unusual
there's certainly been a lot of rain but
there have been a lot of days
and nights that have been clear so being
able to see stars
in december in the pacific northwest is
pretty rare and we've had a lot of
um not last night not really no no it
was cloudy at the peak
um well and i think also it's just oh
the moon was
new or close to it yeah yeah i'm gonna
just look into that
i like to know that and i don't know
it's hard to see yeah exactly
so um yeah i just also say i noticed
that uh
lex is it friedman or fredman i think
it's friedman
yeah alex friedman yeah it's really
close to me uh something
that i would say is akin to toughening
yourself up he was
he's apparently a runner and he was
talking about forcing himself to go out
and he really didn't want to but he was
going to go anyway and
do some six or eight miles which is a
lot of running yeah
um anyway so it's uh
it's good for i've forgotten what we
were um we don't really have much to say
about
wim hof oh right so the question is is
it is it that sort of thing
is it a mindfulness exercise or is there
something specific about the physiology
surrounding
breath control and uh cold and my guess
is
there's some of both my guests i agree
you know it could be a sweat lodge it
could be cold either way
yeah and then there's probably something
specific okay discord question and then
we have to get on to this
today's questions um what effects are
had on the brain of a child who grows up
malnourished yet
full someone who eats chips and beef
jerky every day and drinks soda pop
instead of water
obviously this is bad for the health and
development of a child but how does it
specifically affect the brain once this
child has reached adulthood
um it's an amazing question um i want to
say just two
little things for us before letting you
riff a little bit but i think we do have
to start moving faster through these
um i'm sure we don't know is part of the
question
um and i have one objection uh
which is chips and soda pop for sure not
real food not stuff you should be eating
and i say that is people who have chips
in the house
but beef jerky depending on what it is
uh you know your mom used to make jerky
right like you would have it on with
when you took it backpacking so like
real real beef jerky there's nothing
wrong with that yeah that's
that's real food and you know especially
we're not going to talk a lot about
diets right here but if
if for whatever reason you are trying a
very low carbohydrate diet
um concentrated concentrated meat well
flavored without
additives and preservatives nothing
nothing junky about that as food
no i'd say you and i have both
come to the conclusion based not only on
what's written about it but just the
ability to anecdotally generate
a pattern that uh sugar is
very destructive yeah and you know i can
a day in which i have had substantial
sugar is just
different than one in which i haven't um
i was gonna say the potato chip thing i
don't think potato chips are a great
thing because it's very easy to eat
way too many of them yes it is but
there's nothing about
the potato or the fact that it's fried
um i suspect most even though we buy you
know the
shishi organic potato chips and all of
this that
um that unless they're changing at the
oil frequently and using really high
quality oil to begin with
you've got a lot of like yeah and the
i don't even remember all the different
kinds of fats and what they turn into
okay but then even that then the point
is
it's the mass-produced chip it's not
anything inherent about a chip
yeah if i if we go downstairs and thinly
slice
three pounds of potatoes and put a bunch
of high quality yeah
right yeah it's not it's not the best
you know it's not something that you
should be eating
every single day it's not ideal and it's
easy to eat too many of them but there's
nothing inherently wrong with the
components
yes yeah okay good um so but the actual
question
yeah so those were the those were my
little that was my one nitpicky
uh concern about it uh what effects are
had in the brain of a child who grows up
malnourished yet full
yeah no idea more worried about the
sugar than the others but also i would
say
it depends what you mean so there's a
brain level
in which i think we're going to have to
hunt because we just don't know yeah and
i think
i don't i think we don't know i don't
know maybe none of us know you and i
don't know
we definitely don't know how to punt but
then there's the other side which is the
mind side
so uh borrowing from
uh i think it's neurobiologist sql
not sure but the mind is what the brain
does
right it's a great distinction to the
extent that you need
one here and the point is you might have
impacts on the physiology and
neurobiology
of the brain based on
nutrition and i would say sugar would be
the suspect on that list
but in part because the brain
runs on carbohydrate but the other thing
is
the wiring of the mind will be different
in light of a diet that res that has you
know some sort of
burst of uh sugar for example
that it will rewire the motivational
structures potentially
and um that i would say is a place to
look
for consequences that are not so
desirable from such a diet
is the you know what it does to your
ability to focus
and motivate later in the absence of
those kinds of concentrated
rewards yeah very good
first question from this last hour so
i'll read this and then we will get back
to it
next time hi heather and brett i slid a
thought experiment your way via the
moderator
email kayaking and existential threats
would be super cool if you could riff on
it in this episode or a future episode
um so we'll we'll get back to that next
time
cool here we have a s it's a great title
yeah it is
here we have a two-part question or
maybe it's just a two-part super chat
in his portal interview eric accused
brett of giving away his power
do you agree with him on this either
then or now
how would you counsel others who might
be giving away theirs as well as how to
stop doing that
i often find that if i have a problem i
can't solve it myself that it's much
easier to help someone else who's
struggling with that same problem
is that the case for you love you both
happy hanukkah merry christmas
okay i need to catch up on the second
part here i often find that i have a
problem i can't solve myself it's much
easier to help someone else who's
struggling with that same problem that's
an interesting insight
is that the case for you okay so
um you know this is this is tough and
you know you want to navigate
family issues on your podcast how smart
is that to do
but i will say you know i think a all of
us
tend to assume that other people's
internal wiring is very like our own
this is the basis of empathy we've made
this argument here
multiple times and this argument is
justified
at different levels right there are
things that can make somebody else's
mind look very much like yours and
things that can make you look very
different and your ability to
intuit what's going on on the other side
is um
predicated on there being overlap in a
relevant place
i think there's a way in which eric does
not
always understand the differences
between us as well as he might
and the it is possible that he
objectively sees something that i do not
see
and that he is alerting me some
something i don't know
it is also possible that he is sort of
misunderstanding
what the tools available are and what
the problems addressed are and what the
strength of some other mode might
be and so i don't know the answer to the
question i
let's put it this way if eric says it
i'm all ears
doesn't make him right but but i'm
certainly
listening to any any critique of that
sort and my guess would be
that there's a mixture that there's some
part of the problem
that he doesn't see some way in which uh
you know the point is he's he's
imagining that something
it wouldn't work for him uh or
maybe that's not what he's not imagining
it but he's over assuming that
and therefore applying it where it's not
as relevant and then there's probably
some degree to which he sees something
which is observable from the outside you
know how
x approach works in various
contexts and so he may see a place where
to use the economic terminology i'm not
at the efficient frontier and that is to
say i could
increase effectiveness without a cost
because i haven't found the trade-off
line yet
so i don't know well you may not be at
the efficient frontier
efficient frontier yeah but you're a
truly remarkable man
that's a great answer nice all right i'm
feeling it first seven points now this
yeah yeah but there's no points
associated with this
have you reviewed the scientific
literature regarding ever mectin
and kovid dr pierre corey testified to
the senate in december i can't find
articles in the mainstream media
discussing his claims other than to
state that there is no evidence
i have not i don't i don't know i
have some vague recognition of the word
um but um but i don't know it um and
we will maybe try to get back to it and
look into it but there are a lot of
things to look into
okay so here's just a series of comments
before we get back to questions
just get your vacs and enjoy a nice
lolly there are no 100 guarantees in
life let's talk about something more
important like a little wayne
doesn't the second amendment apply to
black people free little wayne
i don't know what happened a little
wayne
i i think this commenter is right um
i don't know where i would get a lolly
but probably they're widely available i
think we could probably source a lot of
amazon
yeah yeah amazon oh totally yeah
yeah any lollies you find in the amazon
you might want to just clean off first
yes and taste just a little bit before
you go uh
whole hog on the wall definitely taste a
little wait a couple hours
check in with your consciousness totally
yeah ayahuasca
follow up on still life for brett
artists still use a reference for what
they don't yet know how to draw
think of said reference as a sample data
set used to entrain
ai in supervised learning before it
improves upon them
hell yeah cool next comment i just want
you two to know next to watching college
football my favorite thing to do on
saturdays is hang out with you guys in
your sauna
thank you this sauna is surprisingly
cold for a sauna i must say
but yes yes it's a chili sauce it's a
new thing it's like hot yoga chili sauna
it's a
it's the next big thing yeah yeah thank
you for your podcast much appreciated
game theory is often
quoted mentioned i would say never
mentioned my evolution classes at
edinburgh in
edinburgh in early 70s what book
what book would you recommend to a
beginner to eat a grass with game theory
um yeah i always i get asked this so
much yeah and there's just there's not
a good text well i mean i don't know
machine has a chapter
yeah so actually i know but you do need
more but actually i've never
i've never had any answer to this and
selfish gene which is just
extraordinary in every regard it we need
a new one
brett um but um
but you know published in 1976 and still
the
book that will open people's eyes to an
evolutionary way of thinking
um i i do think there's a solid chapter
in there in which he goes through some
of the thinking on game theory but
that's from
there it's just limited in its scope
yeah um
so i don't know that there isn't a good
text um
i don't know i don't know what it is and
i don't i also
if i don't given the way my brain works
if you don't know it it may mean that
it's crossed your back if
i've never read it like i've never been
exposed to that book
because at this point this question has
been asked so many times
i it would have come up in my
consciousness i don't know
of a book that exists and i would like
to yeah and it's not one of the many
many books that i
would like to write i'm not going to
write a game theory book but i also
don't think you need it
right i think you can source because so
many of these things are just sort of
canonical uh flaws
that you detect once you've seen it once
and then the question is can you map it
on to other things right
you are just asking to be asked to just
simply create a series of
six minute youtube videos of the
canonical flaws right well indeed
um on the other hand i might not be the
right guy to do it and i know that uh
david sarak who was a long time patron
of mine
participated in conversations quite an
amazing
mind um he was working on animations
that um that uh explain these things and
you know little video games that allow
you to experience them
great um i don't know what happened to
that but i should contact him and find
out
um and actually maybe we could team up
so that his stuff
would get a wider audience and uh i
think it would be great
but even if what you did and i don't
know that this will work because i
haven't done it but
um if you went to the wikipedia page
on game theory and you found you know
the
canonical 810 uh
puzzles that are commonly described and
then
you uh you know i'm not arguing that
every youtube video on these things is
going to be any
good but if you then went to youtube and
you looked at a description of these
things and maybe you looked at several
descriptions and tried to figure out
what you could what you could deduce my
guess is you would very quickly realize
that game theory is a way of thinking
and that that way of thinking is
something you can bootstrap
and then every time somebody adds a new
puzzle the point is you already have the
language on which it's based and it
becomes
relatively simple to just add the new
puzzle or the new insight
well i will say i just i did what you
just suggested in just wikipedia
game theory and it does say here i've
never read the book but that von neumann
who really originated the formalization
of game theory with
two-person zero-sum games wrote a book
along with
oscar morgenstern in 1944 theory of
games and economic behavior
and the thing about game theory is that
it's timeless so the examples will be
dated but
um the actual game theory is timeless so
that might well be a way in
although being from that long ago uh it
may be in a
kind of language that is even harder to
access than game theory language would
otherwise be
yeah or it could be just the opposite
could be just the opposite i don't i'm
not i don't know morgan stern i'm not
familiar with von neumann's writing so i
don't know
um how which of those will be the case
in this case i don't know
yeah i don't know uh okay next question
i don't know what this means um mimetic
theory a la gerard
desire scapegoat revelation that's my
medic
yes you're right mymatic theory ally
gerard
comma desire slash scapegoat slash
revelation
yep comma might fit evergreen oh yeah
parentheses desire equals to be in your
classroom
and defund the police parentheses desire
equals to succeed in a meritocracy
is it seen in other primates is it
really a theory
so i don't know anything about what's
going on here okay so i'm not deeply
schooled in gerard but i know a bit
okay um the the basic idea he's got a
model
i think he's now this is dead renee
jordan yeah is that right
um i like vaguely know that guy exists
right this guy yep yeah um
so anyway he uh i believe he was at
stanford
is that right is that reflected here i
don't know i see
yeah just literary criticism critical
theory anthropology theology psychology
mythology sociology economics cultural
studies
and philosophy everything over there
bibliography
institutions duke bryn mawr johns
hopkins
yeah suny buffalo stanford okay so
um i believe uh he was a great influence
on peter thiel
among other people i know that he was a
great influence i believe he was also a
mentor to peter thiel at one point
but in any case he has a um
i want to be careful i know it was at
least a hypothesis is it now a theory i
don't know that would depend on whether
or not has been tested
but a very compelling hypothesis a model
essentially
of scapegoating that there is a need to
find
a an individual who can basically take
the burden of the sins of a
society or something smaller and that
these things are
essentially projected onto that person
who is then
treated accordingly and what the
questioner is suggesting
is that i guess i was the designated
scapegoat for
um the the sins of evergreen and
uh it's not the first time i've heard
that uh argument leveled
and i think there's a lot to it i will
also say that before i was aware
of gerard's scapegoat theory the actual
evergreen
stuff unfolded and as i've mentioned a
few times
i believe it was either the day before
or two days before
the protest at my classroom that became
so famous
i had put a model on the board of
witch hunting and if i can do it off the
top of my head hopefully i can
model was something like a tiny number
of people
will initiate a witch hunt a small
number of people
will go along with them a large number
of people
will pretend it isn't happening and a
tiny number of people
will oppose it and the ones who will
oppose it become the witches
right so my guess is these two things
are not so distantly related and the
reason that i put it on the board was
not you know it wasn't
it was impressive i was experiencing
what was going on on the faculty side
and so i was sort of watching myself
portrayed
as the witch and it was therefore on my
mind why is witch hunting a thing
why am i feeling that this is happening
to me right what does it mean and so i
was thinking through these things and
sharing it with my class which is what i
always did i was right whenever i happen
to be thinking about i was sharing with
them
and so this caused a great many students
in that class at the point that this
thing happened and i was demonized
clearly as a witch it caused a great
many of them to ask
if i might have orchestrated the thing
in order to teach this lesson
really really well you are that good
deeply invested in the education of your
students right you would upend your
entire life in that of your family and
careers and yes
yes no um but the funny thing the
punchline to that story to the extent
that there is one
is that months later i would come to
understand that
the lead protester the guy who
set up the protest at my classroom who
organized on video
the kidnapping of the administrators and
the keeping them
in the room to negotiate the prevention
of the
president from going to the bathroom all
that the lead guy
put out on his facebook page a couple
days before the protest of my classroom
one of these you won't know because
you're not on facebook but one of these
things where you can have a square of
color and it just has like a
slogan it's like twitter on facebook
okay and it was something
very close to never before
have white men experienced what it is to
be hunted as witches
or something like this it was clearly
the thing i was very cautious about
saying that i was being
hunted as a witch because it seemed like
that could be hyperbole
but the weird thing was he actually used
that language right
and what had not occurred to me is that
anybody would use witch hunt in the
positive sense
everybody knows that a witch hunt is um
a
an appalling group think
uh embarrassment right and to see it
used positively
shocked me yeah well there was a lot
shocking there wasn't there
yeah so much from an evolutionary
perspective why is a sunset beautiful
why is anything beautiful and do you
think animals other than humans find
beauty in
things oh such a good question yeah
um you have a you go okay
so one i don't know why i sense sunset
is beautiful and it may not be that the
sunset itself is beautiful it may be the
the
i mean obviously the sun beauty is
subjective
so the fact why is the sunset something
that we regard as beautiful
it may be that there is something about
paying attention to the sunset
that we need to be rewarded for in order
that you know to just
take a proof of concept if there was
something about
monitoring the exact in fact there is
the exact location on the horizon where
the sun goes down
and being able to infer patterns about
the year based on
the transition of the sun across that
landscape then you might be called upon
that is to say
you might be rewarded for paying such
close attention to the sun
that you're actually watching it right
when it hit the horizon so that
at the point that it fell it fell just
left of the oak tree
right right and whenever it falls just
left at the oak tree if we don't harvest
within two weeks then we lose the crop
right something like that um and in fact
all of these stonehenge-like
uh celestial clocks that are built in
stone around the world there's one at uh
inga parka perka in um the kanyari and
inca
coming together in southern ecuador yeah
but these things are all over the place
and these things are basically
physical structures that allow you to
know where to stand and where the ray of
light has to come through in order to
hit that thing that tells you exactly
where in the year you are which is a way
of solving a problem
that in europe when people were trying
to calculate a solution to the problem
they inevitably got wrong because it's
not an integer
right the number of days in the year is
very easy to get
wrong by some number
when you do that you get a calendar that
works pretty well and less so over time
it's really useful to have an empirical
check right so it may be that that's
it is that it's calling us to check in
with the sun as it sets
often enough that we are able to detect
where we are in the year and
recalibrate and you know the bigger
question is that in general the things
that are beauty
beautiful that we find beautiful is our
is our subjective overlay over those
things that are objectively
uh good for us or have been good for us
and rare enough
in our history that desiring them
desiring them desiring them didn't cause
problems as they often do now
right so it's a it's a proxy for value
and
i think the the important thing here
maybe the new thing here is that
there is a hypothesis fairly well
advanced
about beauty being a proxy for
value in other words a landscape that we
would regard as beautiful
as one that is liable to be productive
and hospitable right
so that kind of thing causes you to feel
good about it and it causes you to be
more likely to settle there than a
landscape that isn't beautiful and
would be more would be harsher it's
interesting though like um you know a
saharan dunescape
of which there have been you know many
many gorgeous photographs
taken right it's beautiful in the same
way like a modern
modern architecture is yeah it's
beautiful for its starkness for its
spareness
not for any sense that like that could
actually support me that's an
interesting question why is it anything
other than ugly
yeah um given how frighteningly
dangerous it is right
but okay so you've got beauty is a
reward system that causes you to feel
favorable to things that are likely to
be good for you
and then in the case of the sunset
beauty is a proxy
for it's a reward for getting you to pay
attention to something that is
informative it's not that the sunset is
good for you or bad for you
it's that the sunset is informative
which is good for you and your sense of
beauty
tags it to memory yeah perhaps great i
like that
if you could aim machine learning at any
single problem
what would it be and how would you
formulate the question
wow is the assumption here that it would
be successful
um yeah yeah i think so
okay i think i know i know the problem i
don't yeah i i would i need
to think on this i don't have anything
off the top of my head it's the fourth
frontier
we have a problem that we have to solve
the problem is we need
a steady state that feels like growth
so that we don't kill ourselves pursuing
growth
and that steady state has to solve the
problems it has to be
anti-fragile it has to free people
to be to
seek meaningful
meaningful things to do with their time
in other words
so somehow we have to step off of the
treadmill that has us
pursuing new niches because they're not
out there and we have to stop
bludgeoning each other over
technological progress but we have to
not frustrate the human desire
for progress that is built in and
that's not such an easy problem to solve
so if machine learning could figure out
how to do this
and if it could um avoid
you know the fly in the ointment of the
fourth frontier idea is that
to the extent that anybody figures out
the solution it's not clear that they
beat somebody in competition
who decides it's not an important
problem and so
i don't know if the intent of the
question was that machine learning
would be able to search any tractable
problem i believe this problem is
tractable
it's hard to find a good solution but if
machine learning could
help us find it or at least tell us
where to look that would be
amazing next question
people tested positive for hiv with
australia's vaccines because
copenhagen's rna
has 18 fragments of hiv in it
covet 19's dna was sequenced uh it'll be
rna but uh wait yeah was sequenced by
indian scientists who found the hiv
yep media heavily censored this finding
i n said uh
i don't know what i n s said that
coronavirus is lab made
people won't get two parts people won't
get full blown hiv from the mra
mrna vaccines but they will get enough
rna to test positive for hiv
because cover 19 has hiv in it data will
help your immune system
well there's a lot in that and there's a
lot there that at least
maps on to the history here so there
were two so the only thing
well i don't know about the second half
of the first question which is the claim
that the reason people tested positive
for hiv is because
cova-19's rna has 18 fragments of hiv
in it well i don't know let's put it
this way
and i'm going from memory here um i've
long since let the hiv connection go
cold because
uh it was uh very difficult to interpret
but there was an indian paper which i
think was retracted
which argued that there was a hiv
sequence
in sars kovi ii
and there was also uh a
very um nuanced
analysis done by the
french co-discoverer of hiv
um in which he claimed that there was
hiv
sequence oh this is months ago no
this was back in march yeah
yeah yeah yeah um so anyway
i never knew what to make of it right i
also don't know whether there
is any mechanism that could naturally
include
hiv sequence could you get a convergence
probably not
is there some other mechanism which
where there would be exchange of
information
related yeah i mean they're not even the
same
type of virus so um anyway i don't know
what to make of it it is
certainly possible that a
laboratory that was attempting to create
a virus for
research could borrow themes from
two different kinds of viruses that's
right um and so
i have no reason to believe that this
happened other than
that a controversial but highly
accomplished
french researcher argued that something
like this was the case
and that there was a paper then
retracted and what does one make of a
paper that was retracted and also
controversial but
may or may not have been accurate
yeah so i don't know what to make of it
but anyway
i would say the second part of the
question about whether or not
that means you know people won't get
full-blown hiv
from mrna vaccines i don't believe even
if these things trigger um
hiv tests that there's any danger of
getting any level of anything like hiv
if you have
a mechanism here yeah um uh and what's
more
the key thing that's missing that will
prevent anything like hiv from happening
is reverse transcriptase yeah so
people who followed all of these live
streams will remember back at the
beginning i made an error that i then
quickly corrected where i had assumed
that coronaviruses reverse transcribed
and
inserted themselves into the genome
which they don't do
so this is a special trick of
retroviruses
and because coronaviruses are mrna
viruses that don't uh reverse transcribe
and hiv
is a retrovirus that does there's
i would argue essentially no danger of
picking up anything aids-like even if
the sequences are there because without
that enzyme and we don't make that
enzyme as far as i know
um i just don't see i don't see the
hazard
but it is interesting whether or not
those sequences
are what these two groups claimed they
were
right which is hiv sequences which then
raises all kinds of interesting
questions yes it does
okay let us do two more here and then it
looks like we've only got
a few in the new hour so we might be
able to get through all
of the next hours ones unless suddenly
we get a
lot more okay might we just be tiptoeing
around the possibility that democracy is
becoming ever less efficient as global
issues become ever more salient in
relation to local ones
is techno is technocracy the only way to
steer such a big ship
well hope not i wouldn't say that
democracy is becoming
less efficient it's becoming less
coherent
and the reason is becoming less well
maybe that results in inefficiency
the reason it's becoming less coherent
is as you hint in your
question you've got issues of scale you
know
you are allowed to we have some issues
some matters of scale built into our
democracy we can vote on state issues
local issues
and federal issues we cannot vote on
international issues except indirectly
that our state can sort of navigate them
in theory on our behalf but we have lots
of issues in which our well-being is
actually dictated by things that happen
above the scale of nations so
the i would say the subtlety of the
connections between cause and effect the
scale of our industrial processes all of
these things
oh and the fact that not only you know
the founders
feared that the common person was not
going to understand the issues well
enough
to govern well which is why we don't
have a direct democracy
at least one of the reasons and so we
were supposed to get
a chamber of
thoughtful people and experts to
navigate these things on our behalf and
the problem is you know we've got a
chamber of lawyers
right that's not exactly a great group
to be navigating
difficult issues of you know uh cause
and effect in a complex system
um and this is still true chamber of
lawyers
yeah yeah i think it is i think it is
mostly lawyers
i'll be interested if something i i i
feel certain that it
was mostly true but i'm not it feels to
me like it's been changing of late
well it would have to change an awful
lot for not to be a majority of them but
um but in any case the problem is
the nature of these questions is very
hard to navigate
the public isn't going to get it the
chamber of lawyers isn't going to get it
to the extent of the chamber of lawyers
is being replaced by
others it's not being replaced by people
you know experts in
complex systems or any other relevant
discipline so anyway yes we have a
problem we've got difficult issues to
navigate and we have a governmental
mechanism
that is not built for an environment in
which our technology
can upend us in the way that it now can
yep
okay a recent npr poll said that 65
of republican men were planning to take
the vaccine as opposed to only 34
of republican women what do you think
are the psychological reasons for this
divide
well that's surprising to me yeah i
would not
have predicted i would have predicted
the other direction yeah
so uh it's it's always a little dicey to
come up with the
explanations for a result that you find
counterintuitive
right and that you don't even know might
be right um right but let's assume that
the report is correct
um that at least those are the
percentages yep uh here's
one idea so this is a hypothesis which
doesn't mean that i think it's likely to
be true it means that it isn't it is
testable and it might be true and it
fits with the
um supposed observed pattern right
so i know i'm going to say a bunch of
offensive things that i'm not saying are
true but if they were true
would then uh increase the likelihood
that this
hypothesis was predictive go for it okay
so republicans tend to be more
conservative
than democrats is that offensive not yet
okay
conservative is going to involve a
certain amount of
tradition especially with respect to
things like gender roles
does that then imply that a larger
fraction
of republican women are
either at home or expecting
to work from home in a more traditional
capacity
by traditional i just mean back to the
50s i don't mean yeah
long term in which case you could make a
very rational argument
that the general sense that there might
be a hazard
with these vaccines and the
understanding that there is a hazard
with
coronavirus would result in
a distribution of the willingness to
take it that reflected the likelihood of
contacting it in other words if you work
from home
then your risk of contacting somebody
with
covet 19 is lower and so your
cost benefit analysis would favor
not taking it yup yup see it's a
hypothesis that in principle could
explain
this pattern that is observed and it
is testable because it predicts
that if we were to go back into the same
population that
the tendency
either you go back to the same
population or you could test in another
equivalent population
whether or not the likelihood of taking
the vaccine was correlated with the
tendency
to work outside the home although in
your original formulation of the
hypothesis you said
uh do not work outside the home or
have aspirations to not work outside the
home yeah well you could correct it for
that you could say
do you expect in 10 years to be working
in the home
in which case so anyway it would be
those two categories
any correlation between expectation of
working in the home and resistance to
the vaccine
would be sufficient to uh establish
this hypothesis yes containing a
fraction of the truth i don't think it's
right
but it's testable right i just wanted it
to work
yeah and i got nothing else so let's
move on into um
into this oh my goodness um this hour
what a species with what a species with
no or
rare predators be able to evolve human
level consciousness would they at one
point get outperformed by a witty weaker
species
same question for non-violent animals
that don't hunt
like elephants species
with no predators
so human level consciousness immediately
sure what the connection
is between not having predators and
consciousness
i i think that um actually the model
that we have and this part of the model
is almost
is it was was well developed already by
dick alexander
at the point that we were working with
him in grad school in the 90s
uh was that it was exactly our this
this sort of not exactly an arm size but
like this like
you know we establish ecological
dominance which allows us to
focus on each other as our biggest
competitor well it is an arms race
it is human lineage rather than that
it's more like the cycle between like
you move into a new space and you have
to dominate your environment before you
can return to seeing each other as your
biggest competitor
but the consciousness is part of what
facilitates that
and it's like the consciousness predates
the lack of predators not the other way
around well i don't think dick's model
included consciousness in the sense no
no we mean it it was about why
human cognitive capacity had grown uh
disproportionately
right the idea was simply
at the point that nature is not
your most pressing concern darwin's
hostile forces
the point you've taken care of darwin's
hostile forces and therefore
you and other human groups are the
biggest factor in each other's success
that is to say the hostility some other
group could
you can dominate a landscape and some of
the group can take it from you
that the arms race is between two human
groups with similar levels of
cognitive capacity and they just amp
each other up
which would then feed into your and my
model of consciousness and its
relationship to language and novel
problem solving and all of that but
i think the i think the simple answer to
this
is until you've got language
human level consciousness is
inconceivable that does not mean
consciousness is inconceivable but human
level consciousness is inconceivable
short of language and so that's not
directly related
to predators it's related to whether or
not you have a problem set like
our human ancestors did where they had
this arms race
and thinking outside the box was the way
you got ahead of your
human competitors so um i think i think
predators are
looming too large in your model um and
that
other humans are the thing you really
need in order to
um to amp up such a thing
next question is just a note to me
heather i sent a private question on
patreon it's long has some identifying
info
could you please help with some advice i
value your and brett's opinion on this
thank you i have made a note to myself
to take a look so i'll do that in the
next
hopefully it's not super timely we have
a critical deadline
wednesday so um if i don't do it before
wednesday
um i hope that's okay but i'll do it um
soon thereafter if not before
regarding oh so this is from the same
person who wrote about the equity
requirements for
faculty regarding equity requirements i
was indeed asking
about equity statements and requirements
for my psychology research to target
equity
thanks for answering oh so that this
it's a bit
different than what i was what i was
reading it as
um and boy if you're actually i mean
if i'm not reading that correctly how i
how i interpret that is
um you know i mean there's an honorable
there's an honorable interpretation here
which is that
increasingly we are coming to understand
that
um the the weird capitals
all capitals western educated
industrialized rich democratic
country people especially weird
psychology undergraduates
who have been the subjects of almost all
of the major psychology experiments and
therefore are the people on whom most of
the major psychological findings
of the 20th and 21st century are based
are not actually representative of the
rest of the world that we are actually
outliers that we are we are we are the
weirdos
so you know we're sort of accurate it's
an accurate acronym
in which case we really should be
encouraging a lot of different kinds
of subject pools for such research
that said it's a hell of a lot easier if
you are faculty at a university
to get fat to get psychology
undergraduates to come in and take
and participate um than it is to get
people from your surrounding community
and that itself is a lot easier than it
is
to become you know a field psychologist
and go
to the arctic or the african savannah or
wherever it is else that you might go
and discover things about the brains of
of such people who live in such
places and yes absolutely we should know
so but i was actually
for the book i was just uh reading some
you know really foundational amazing
work from the 60s
on how um culture affects
the development of the of the visual
cortex of our actual
ability to perceive things and you know
we know this and we've known this for
over 50 years
of course there are going to be all
sorts of different truths
about how it is that we perceive reality
honestly and how it is that we convey it
and discuss it and share it depending on
what our developmental environment was
so there's value for sure and not having
weird psych undergrads be the subject
pool for all of these psych experiments
but
being forced to expand your pool
because of because of that need is uh
potentially more onerous than
it's worth as an individual researcher
excellent
okay phenomic
trait studies recover microevolution
deep time genomic gene studies
match flamingos with grebes and worse
mismatches
genes work great for crime fighters why
not for paleontologists
i'm not sh i think it's possible there's
something here that i'm not reading but
i think
phenomic isn't a word i recognize and i
wonder if we mean
phylogenetic or phenotypic and i wonder
if instead of paleontologists he means
phylogeneticists or phylogenetic
systematists and i want to interpret it
that latter way but since i'm not sure
that's what
yeah what do you think what do you think
is meant here i am not sure what has
meant
i would say that i think that
there is a reason to distinguish micro
and macroevolution and i would say
it is speciation um but
the
i would argue that the distinction is
overdrawn and that in effect
what you get is microevolution uh
produces macroevolution
we talked i think in a recent podcast
about
um the
question of whether or not uh as i have
argued
in various places speciation is adaptive
rather than uh
an epiphenomenon plays into that but
nonetheless the way you've drawn it
you've got
microevolution is effectively um
well you know we don't have the question
on the screen here anymore but
sorry i'm looking up the the graves work
but in any case i i i wonder if you
haven't drawn too much of a dichotomy
that
uh doesn't deserve to be drawn and that
if they're if they're not really just
the same process at different scales and
therefore um
one only needs to modify their thinking
accordingly
yeah um so i will say
that so i remembered you know i
i used to teach the systematics of
vertebrates
um and i remember this grave flamingo
thing so
zack you can put up my screen for just a
second this i think is the research to
which the person is referring this 2001
paper in the royal society
um called convergence and divergence in
the evolution of aquatic birds which yes
indeed finds that flamingos
and um grebes are sister taxa which
seems incredibly surprising given they
don't look anything alike
and um sure it's possible that in this
case the dna are misleading and this
isn't
uh this isn't actually accurate but it's
also
quite possible that um
that it is you know the thing some
clades just evolved very very rapidly
and we don't know you know maybe
presumably if they really are sister the
most recent common ancestor of the
flamingos and griebs probably looked a
lot more like one of those than the
other it would be unlikely for both of
them to have
shot you know changed tremendously um
but
you know you have you have living taxa
that look a lot like they did 200
million years ago crocodilians
probably right sharks for sure
and then you have things that have
changed incredibly rapidly so i also i
just did a very
you know this in terms of just like
checking the logic on the question
i just did a google scholar search on
the paper in question and then did a and
looked at the forward
uh here's zach if you could show my
screen because this is just something
useful that people can do
so i just went to google scholar and
plugged in this paper
and so here it is it's been cited 166
times which isn't a ton
from 2001 and then you look at where
it's been cited
and you know i've just done this so i
have not
i don't have time to assess this right
now but one thing that comes up right
away is that it looks like
there are no modern citations nope there
are there are modern citations
15 modern citations since 2016
but it falls off dramatically so does
that mean
that newer work has has replaced that
estimation i don't know with you know
half an hour of devoted
focus here i could i could figure out
whether or not we
meaning systematists think that that
result
was was wrong either because there is a
problem in the heuristics used by the
systematic software or the data were bad
or the analysis used to few birds or
whatever it was to futaxa
okay but as a to your point about the
possibility that the
the work is actually robust yeah um look
up these three
critters and show images uh
hyrax oh right okay
let me just get them all before uh
before zach shows anything okay so we're
gonna do high rocks
and then we're gonna do yeah there we go
i think everyone knows what an elephant
looks like but
and uh how about a
a dugong
okay so you can show my screen zach uh
these are dugongs um
dewgongs which are serenians they're
relatives of
aren't they sea cows aren't they
hippopotamus
no no they're elephants
yes these are elephants hyraxes and
serenity i think the plural is high
reeks
um and the weight yeah i love the high
so everyone knows what elephants look
like we also know there's two different
two lineages of elephants but then the
high reeks
there are also a couple lineages of
hyrax but elephants is good
group by the it's monophyletic it's not
that the high reefs are
more closely related to african
elephants i think all of these each of
them are monophyletic
the hyraxes are a good group the
sirenians are a good group and the
i'm not i'm not a good group the pro
obsidians are yeah
and anyway they are robust
i believe the work is robust it says
they're actually each other's closest
living relative which does you know
which way that goes or is that a
polytomy at the base there
i think the higher axes are basil
and uh really yeah oh interesting i
believe so
i thought it was high reeks and
elephants um i just like to say hi rakes
okay um
cool um
three more questions and then we're done
for the for the week here um
i don't usually like jazz but i like the
campfire song how do we plan for
american unity going forward
uh how do um plan for american unity
we're just going to do it i mean that's
the thing
that turns back the haemophilus back
hemipdrams being true bugs
nope and they totally suck yeah they
totally suck i'm gonna throw this one
out the window
you're gonna have to uh all right um
all right well with her throwing the
hemifer out the window it's now time
that we can talk about her
and she will be in no position to uh to
respond um
all right i was answering a question
about what we do about
american unity and the answer is we are
going to have to
uh to fight for it because obviously the
duopoly
is more than capable of defending itself
with one hand tied behind its back based
on its immense power
over policy and narrative and um
even one brain died behind its back i'm
not sure they've got one brain between
them but uh
but nonetheless i just don't see any
alternative we have to
we have to bootstrap it and at the
moment uh it's on pause before the
inauguration is that right
yeah effectively yeah yeah it's on pause
until uh it's
time you know exactly what we would be
doing now um yeah
so anyway uh yes stay tuned you will uh
you will see things happen at the point
that um
there is opportunity to
to make trouble yeah all right two more
questions
i am doing a debate tomorrow with a
party who thinks that children aren't
mature enough to decide their gender and
everyone should be on blockers
help oh my god that i actually have not
heard something true twisted
into that conclusion before someone who
thinks that children aren't mature
enough to decide their gender
they're exploring identity that's what
children do and
therefore everyone should be on blockers
so a blockers is about
sex is about transform
trying to transform all the parts of sex
that you can without actually getting to
anything fundamental because you can't
so wait wait this person thinks that
children should be put on blockers
so this is going to be puberty blockers
it's going to be crazy sexy it's not
cross-sex hormones it's
actual blockers so i mean look there's
only there's only one argument against
this
and that is who the hell do you think
you are yeah
who the hell do you think you are that
you know so much about this stuff that
you are in a position to disrupt
normal development you know what this
reminds me of this reminds me of
in researching the book i came across a
movement
in the early 20th century among american
medical doctors
who had um they were worried about the
appendix and it's this vestigial organ
and couldn't figure out what it was good
for and
um we're not going to tell that whole
story now but it turns out it's actually
good for a lot of things and it depends
on
on your environmental context but they
then went
i dare say it's like eight or twenty
steps further and they decided that
not only were they certain that the
appendix was not good for anything but
the large intestine
was actually useless and they were
advocating for just getting rid of it
because
it's clearly not doing anyone any good
this this is
that kind of batshit naivete that's even
worse
it's even worse i mean you know it's
kids it's development like
yeah they're gonna destroy people
they're going to destroy people this is
just completely unacceptable
and uh i mean just even even at the
point that somebody
formulates such an argument says it out
loud and doesn't immediately understand
that what they've said is insane
um we got a serious problem there's
something there's something in this and
i ran into this with
um sort of like really
dim faculty
who had been semi-trained in humanities
or social sciences but not like the
legit humanities and social sciences
these are just
dim post-modern critical theory
humanities social science types
who seem to really believe that
um everything about the universe was
created at the point that humans started
talking about that thing
like that that's actually the the
foundational premise of a lot of this
stuff you'd be talking like
well you know of course darwin darwinism
is racist no it's not
well these people who were talking about
it were racist
like just because the thing has been
abused by idiots and racists doesn't
make it
idiotic or racist and you know
children are interested
in figuring out who they are and in
being transgressive
and in exploring limnality and in
in doing all of the exploration that is
what
children are about that's why we have
the longest developmental periods
relative to our lifetime on the planet
you should therefore conclude exactly
the opposite yeah
you don't mess with their development
with giving them exogenous
drugs you don't do it unless it is
absolutely a hundred percent required
by for some reason that is distinct to
them
for which nothing else has worked and
everything else that should be tried
first
includes everything from diet to
exercise to light regime
to family situation all of these things
you don't start with drugs and
hopefully you never you don't end with
drugs and accept the rarest cases
that's insane yeah that's that's it's
insane
one more question yep totally different
oh no actually not
a little bit it's children how to
evaluate covered vaccines for a
two-year-old and a five-year-old i'm
usually pro-vaccine but apprehensive
given the novelty of the mrna mechanism
for what it's worth kids are
homeschooled i would say no
i mean in fact i think even even the
authorities who are pushing this for
absolutely everyone
are saying under i've seen actually a
couple of age ranges but i've never seen
anyone
advocating for under six-year-olds yeah
and first you know and homeschooled
they're at low risk anyway but like
absolutely not for tiny kids
they also will not have tested these
vaccines on kids so
right as far as i'm concerned kids
should be exempt for multiple reasons
yeah um not only aren't they getting
covet but they're actually apparently
not even transmitting it
so it's not even that they're vectors
and they themselves don't get sick
but you know yes there have been a few
cases but not only are the schools
mostly coveted free
um but when there are outbreaks it's
going between adults and very rarely are
the children even involved as vectors
so um like just keep it away from the
kids yeah keep it away from the kids and
really
i think we should set a fairly high age
i've seen 16.
yeah but i'm not even talking about 16
i'm talking about
how how do you hedge against the kinds
of unknowns that come with a vaccine
like this
yeah one way would be to decide that the
people who are
in least danger of getting it and
suffering severe consequences
be the ones who are exempted so that um
we don't
create a catastrophe yeah i would be i
would be inclined to exempt people below
i don't know 30. well the argument then
goes
um yeah i mean this this is complicated
um maybe the group uh that should be
getting mass vaccinated first or the
so-called party animals you know the
people who are at the center
of of social groups when people you know
people like nicholas christakis do their
you know social uh network types of
analyses that the people who
have many many many more connections
than anyone else are the ones who are
most likely to be spreading it
if they have whatever that additional
like magic ingredient is that makes them
super spreaders which may have
nothing to do with their social behavior
and it may have everything to do
um i think if it did have everything to
do with the social behavior we would
know that already though yeah is there
i i don't know is there any indication
that super spreader-ness
is about some individual characteristic
rather than
uh an environment that's super conducive
well this is this is
i think you just sort of asked exactly
the question that i was trying to get at
as well
that um i think
that if it was just behavioral
uh that that would be clear by now and
given that one of the
few people who's really on this is
nicholas christakis and he
is rock solid in terms of his analytical
skills and this is exactly squarely in
his wheelhouse
because he's both a sociologist who
studies social networks and also an md
and actually just came out with this
book that i haven't seen yet and
this year about cobin 19 um
that we would have some sense of super
spreaders really being a behavioral
thing
and because i haven't seen that i think
that there's going to be something else
sort of epidemiol
ideological about individuals
that is making them super spreaders um
but i but i don't know and i don't i
don't think we know
but i know that i don't know my
suspicion and it may be that there's
something on top of it
is that you know you're going to get
people
who are particularly productive in terms
of aerosolized particles yeah
because of the moment that they are in
contact so in other words if you imagine
an event
there will be some fraction of the
population that is at maximum
productivity of aerosolized
uh just because of the place and the
trajectory of the disease relative to
their own body
when they go to the thing when they go
to the restaurant or the party or
whatever you know you've got
asymptomatic
symptoms jump productivity and then it's
going to drop off so the prediction
there is that everyone
is a super spreader for like 12 hours in
their disease progression
but most people don't hit no i would say
i would say
let's take three items that would
combine to create a super spreader event
super spreader event or individual same
thing okay
you've got uh somebody in their maximum
productivity of aerosolized particle
phase
you've got um an
event that creates the conditions like a
low volume
room without proper circulation and
an activity that causes maximum
production
okay sure but you just black box the
thing we were talking about i don't
think so
the first thing in that list is you know
they're
they're at their most productive so this
this fits with what i just said which is
that you
think that everyone has the capacity to
be a super spreader if they happen
if it happens to be at that point the
trajectory of the disease i
i that is certainly a hypothesis i would
not put money on that hypothesis
i think it is more likely there is
something either either
behaviorally about some people that
makes them um
that and and there's a there's a long
period during which they could be super
spreaders
or more likely there is something else
that we do not
know about their particular genome
phenotype development something that
interfaces with covan 19 particularly
that makes those individual super
spreaders regardless of what else is
true
well it could even be that it isn't
genomic and that it has to do with the
accident of what tissues
are good for force hypothesis yeah
it's tissues that are expect especially
likely to produce aerosolized particles
for example but
i guess my point is super spreader event
is going to be a combination of things
and two of them might have nothing to do
with idiosyncrasies absolutely but
that's why i asked you when you started
this i said are you talking about the
super spreader individual or the event
they're not the same thing well
they are because in each case they're
inherently the same because
in each case we have a super spreader
the fact of a super spreader event
which involves at least one individual
who's spreading
virus in some circumstances a super
spreader event includes a super spreader
individual but they're not the same
thing there's
it's a nested set no my point is there's
no
way to have an individual and no event
right the
individual is intersecting other people
ah well no i i think that that
these hypotheses differ
in that some of them assume that you
could be an individual with the capacity
to be a super spreader who doesn't find
the right event
and that what you are what you are
suggesting is that everyone no matter
what if they end up covet positive
has some period of time when if all of
the other parameters are right
will become a super spreader individual
but that that isn't that there is
nothing unique about them as an
individual that makes them a super
spreader i think we know that's not true
because there are you know there's a
vast range of productivity
in other words there are mild cases what
do you mean productivity of what
aerosolized particles there are lots of
cases in which somebody is expected to
produce very
few of these things over the entire
course of their disease
but some of the super spreaders have
apparently been asymptomatic
so it's not just about um you know the
current model of its aerosolized
particles and that's how you
that's how you spread it so i mean well
it's
it's way more chaotic in terms of
it's it's just not clean well i'm not
saying it is
i'm a little bit doubtful about an
asymptomatic person being a super
spreader maybe you've seen
something i haven't seen i've i've seen
some stuff and i also have one very
strong anecdote
of um just an entire an entire workforce
at an office with something between 10
to 15 people
getting positive after one person who
had just breathed in a room for a couple
of hours without a mask and never showed
any symptoms and then
they all went in there masked for
for a meeting for an hour and every
single one of them came out positive
with it
i can't say it on air okay oh it's a
it's not a published thing no this
that so i i've seen some stuff and i
have to dig it up but this this anecdote
is a situation that i know of personally
okay
um and it you know the person one of the
people
involved and i were talking about it and
um you know they were they were
shocked like no one expected that
someone who was asymptomatic could have
gotten so many people
sick and they never came down with
symptoms it never came down with
symptoms and almost none of the people
who then tested positive came down with
symptoms either and none of them got
really sick
but um all of all of them did and then
none of the people that that office
worked with
you know and they shut down completely
for two weeks and all of this and you
know they didn't
they did not get any of the their people
who they work with as
in terms of the business that they do
sick
um because they were very very careful
to immediately quarantine
um anyway got it yeah
all right oh that was long
yep here we go it is almost four o'clock
here on the west coast which means it's
almost certainly later where you are if
you're listening live
and to people in hawaii lucky dogs
yeah the weather's probably better too
yeah undoubtedly
yeah so um you can see on screen
you can get merch you can
go to either of our patreons join the
discord conversation
get access to the private q a that we do
once a month
two hours more intimate than this
because we actually look at the chat
going on it's many fewer people
um it's been fun yeah we've been
enjoying those
and uh at your patreon for some um
longer more more private conversations
yep
well you know get yourself a mug and uh
when it hits five o'clock have yourself
a portland mug shot
get yourself a portland mug shot yep all
right
i think i think we're there uh we will
see you next week
ciao
[Music]
what
[Music]
you